Hallo.
Ja also wird Geschäftsordnung Schlachten und einstimmen Mehrheiten haben wir heute alles Drama gehabt diese Woche was man sich so vorstellen kann,
und das Ergebnis aus dem Ausschuss zum Urheberrecht ist echt katastrophal aber ich bin noch guter Dinge dass wir das im Plenum noch mal kippen können.
Ja das ist genau richtig also eigentlich läuft es im Parlament meistens relativ konsensorientiert ab und es ist auch so ein bisschen Aufgabe des Ausschusses und des Berichterstatters.
Diesen Konsens zu suchen davon hat aber unser Berichterstatter Axel Voss,
CDU irgendwie wenig gehalten und wollte stattdessen mit dem Kopf durch die Wand auf keinen Fall irgendwie vom Leistungsschutzrecht abrücken obwohl die Kritik immer lauter geworden ist,
und das hat eben dazu geführt dass er am Ende.
Mit 13 zu 12 Stimmen das Leistungsschutzrecht durch den Ausschuss gebracht hat also eigentlich nur von Gnaden des Front National also die beiden.
Außen Abgeordneten im Rechtsausschuss Wandervögel stimmt und nur deshalb hat er überhaupt nicht mehr Halt bekommen und.
Das könnte ihm jetzt aber eben in auf die Füße fallen weil das ganze Parlament,
Anfang Juli ja noch mal entscheiden darf ob sie denn dieses Ausschuss Ergebnis jetzt akzeptieren oder nicht,
und ja also es gab durchaus immer wieder Versuche zu sagen wir können ja irgendwie einen Kompromiss finden bei dem das freie Internet nicht gefährdet wird und trotzdem irgendwie,
den Verlagen und der Musikindustrie am Ende irgendwas übrig bleibt aber dazu war er vor seid überhaupt nicht willens.
Und deshalb haben wir jetzt diesen wirklich katastrophalen Text Wo Upload Filter drin sind wo Leistungsschutz.
Trensen und was vielleicht auch nicht allen so klar ist also das finde ich nur upload-filter sondern diese Plattformen.
Unmittelbar haftbar für jede einzelne Urheberrechtsverletzung ihrer Nutzer das heißt selbst wenn sie irgendwie den neuesten Stand an filtern.
Verlieren die sowieso mehr schlecht als recht funktionieren sobald sie eine Urheberrechtsverletzung nicht erkennen sind sie trotzdem dran.
Also.
Anreize für diese Plattform soviel zu filtern wie nur irgendwie möglich und immer dann wenn auch nur der leise.
Zweifel an der Legalität besteht dass von vornherein nicht zuzulassen also im Prinzip eine Vorzensur zu betreiben denn das ist die einzige Art und Weise wie sie sich nach diesem Vorschlag vor der Haftung Schutz.
Also diese Definition besagt zunächst einmal dass es um Hosting-Provider geht also sie müssen die Inhalte sowohl speichern als auch öffentlich anzeigen das heißt also,
Rheine.
Streaming-Dienste wären davon womöglich nicht erfasst weil sie eben die Inhalte nicht dauerhaft speichern und reine sage ich mal Cloud-Dienste die.
Ausschließlich mit Passwort Zugang gewähren und eben keinen öffentlichen Zugang machen die sind auch draußen aber alle anderen Hosting-Provider sind zunächst mal drin.
Dann wird gesagt okay also es geht um die Hosting-Provider deren Zweck ist ist oder einer ihrer Hauptwerke öffentlichen Zugang zu gewähren.
Das ist meiner Ansicht nach keinen keinen besonders sinnvolles Kriterium um die Definition weiter einzuschränken weil ich denke mir nachher was ist denn der Zweck von Facebook z.b.
Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie die die.
Kunden von Facebook fragen würde die Werbetreibenden dann würden die wahrscheinlich sagen der Zweck von Facebook ist irgendwie Werbung möglichst gezielt an ihre.
Ziele auszuliefern.
Die Nutzer von Facebook würden wahrscheinlich sagen irgendwie der Zwerg ist mit meinen Freunden zu kommunizieren keine Ahnung also das ist ein sehr schwammiges Kriterium und könnte dazu führen dass auf der einen Seite,
so eine Plattform wie Kinder davon betroffen ist wenn man sagt na ja.
Also Kinder hat eigentlich keinen anderen Zweck als Leuten Fotos anzuzeigen das ist irgendwie der Kern dessen was diese App macht aber auf der anderen Seite könnte sein dass Facebook das eigentlich das Ziel dieses Vorschlags war gar nicht betroffen ist.
Weil man sagt nachher der Zweck von Facebook ist eigentlich ein anderer also dieser Zweck.
Meiner Ansicht nach stiftet nur Verwirrung und führt nicht dazu irgendwie zu sagen es ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Und bestimmte Plattform müssen sich keine Sorgen machen und dann gibt's das dritte Kriterium das dritte Kriterium ist.
Diese Plattform die Inhalte nicht einfach nur Husten sondern auch optimieren allerdings ist optimieren so breit definiert.
Das auch so ziemlich alles runterfällt also es wird gesagt optimieren ist z.b. taggen oder displaying also unter displaying stelle ich mir so vor naja also z.b. wenn es kein reiner file locker ist.
Sondern wenn ich das Video oder die MP3 unmittelbar im Browser abspielen kann dann ist das bereits in Optimierung also insofern da wird auch außer ganz ganz simple file or kann eigentlich nicht.
Abgeschlossen das heißt also von dieser Definition sind erstmal so ziemlich alle Provider erfasst und dann gibt es ganz ganz.
Fehrle Ausnahmen und zwar Dienst.
Die mit einem nicht kommerziellen Zweck addieren und Dienste wo sowieso alle recht Inhaber zugestimmt haben die sind drauf.
Und dann wird noch gesagt also.
Die Cloud Services und die online marketplaces sind.
Also das heißt auf der einen Seite eine äh,
lehmbreite Definition und auf der anderen Seite.
So sag mal dein ok alle außer Wikipedia eventuell noch Gitter und eBay.
Also das heißt mein Mann nimmt mir Definition wo erstmal alle drin sind und dann hat sich irgendeine Lobby beschwert um gesagt nee sorry aber für Ebay geht das jetzt wirklich nicht und dann hat man halt geschrieben okay aber ebay ist nicht gemeint.
Das Problem mit diesem mit diesem mit dieser Herangehensweise ist natürlich dass man nur die Plattform ausnehmen kann die man heute schon kennt aber alle die irgendwie Überherrn post,
Erkenntnishorizont hinausgehen weil er von denen noch nie gehört hat oder weil die vielleicht auch noch gar nicht existieren die werden dann filtern müssen.
Genau also in der Definition steht drin.
To store and give access also posten und Zugang geben das heißt also wenn eine Plattform tatsächlich die Inhalte nicht speichert.
Abgesehen hat von der Sekunde in der sie irgendwie gestreamt werden dann wäre die Plattform nicht drin aber jeder Streaming Provider der auch noch irgendwie eine Zeitverzögerung anbietet oder dergleichen der wäre schon von der Definition erfasst.
Nein das wäre ja zu einfach.
Das ist was der Rat fordert also man kann dem rad zumindest zugute halten das ist zumindest theoretisch möglich ist für eine Plattform den Forderungen des Rates zu entsprechen.
Ist zwar nicht gut und es verstößt wahrscheinlich gegen Grundrechte die Plattform zum Filtern zu verpflichten aber wenigstens sagt der Rat also naja wenn die Plattform schon filtert dann ist sie auch aus der Haftung raus.
Das Parlament also der Text von Herrn Voß ist wirklich ja so radikal dass selbst die Plattform die alle Filter,
am Ende immer noch verklagt werden kann weil jeder einzelne Urheberrechtsverletzung die durch den Filter durch schlüpft sofort.
Der Plattform selbst zu gerechnet werden kann und das ist eigentlich noch die viel radikalere Änderung im Grunde genommen weil die das Hosting-Provider Privileg also die Regelung.
Das Provider erst dann haften wenn Sie Kenntnis erlangen davon dass jemand was illegales tut also das komplett abschafft für Urheberrecht und das ist eigentlich schon Wirklichkeit.
Ja und wenn man überlegt.
Ja also so in Deutschland also es gab so auch viel Kritik am netzdg aber der wird trotzdem schon gesagt also irgendwie Haftung gibt,
nur dann wenn es regelmäßig und systematisch Fehler passieren und nicht wenn einmal eine hassbotschaft durchkommt.
Also im ursprünglichen Kommissionsvorschlag gab es eine Verpflichtung zum Filtern aber keine Haftung.
Das heißt also die große Veränderungen gegenüber dem Kommissionsvorschlag ist eben dass die Plattform unmittelbar für die Urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer User haften.
Im Kommissionsvorschlag war das noch so dass ihm gesagt wurde also sie sind verpflichtet.
Filtern und dann wurde in den Erwägungsgründen so ein bisschen argumentiert also dass sie womöglich ja auch nach geltender Rechtslage eh schon haftbar sind aber das stand nicht so.
Glasklar im Text wie das jetzt im Parlament und Rat der Fall ist.
Also das muss man ganz klar sagen und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund weshalb ist gute Chancen gibt das im Plenum noch zu kippen weil hairforce hat einfach.
Übertrieben also er hat einen Kompromiss vorgelegt der radikaler ist als jeder einzelne Änderungsantrag der überhaupt eingereicht wurde und nennt das dann irgendwie einen einen Kompromiss.
Dann muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die Mehrheiten extrem knapp sind und das fehlt um das vielleicht anders.
Beim Upload Filter leider nicht also beim upload-filter war es schlimmer da war es 15 zusehen dass er selbst wenn er vor Nachhinein nicht zugestimmt hätte wäre das,
bekommen weil dort die Konservativen also die Tories,
zugestimmt haben beim Leistungsschutzrecht haben aber die Konservativen dagegen gestimmt und da ging es entsprechend 13.12 aus und es lag ausschließlich an den Stimmen also an den zwei Stimmen bevor national.
Alle also fair vor allen Dingen für die die Plattform verklagen wollen die mich an also die Argument hat,
Sohn von Herrn Voß ist nicht besonders stringent weil der ein oder andere wird ihn schon kennen aus den Verhandlungen zur Datenschutz,
Grundverordnung und da war er der,
und so weiter und das scheint ihn aber überhaupt nicht zu interessieren wenn es jetzt um ums Urheberrecht geht also ist,
keinerlei mildernde Maßnahmen für Kleinunternehmen in diesem Vorschlag im Gegensatz zum Rat der zumindest sagt na ja.
Also wenn es ein ganz kleine Plattform ist dann reicht möglicherweise eben auch dass man die Inhalte im Nachhinein entfernt sowas,
hier nicht also es ist keine so richtige Logik zu erkennen dass hairforce jetzt grundsätzlich immer.
Wie freundlich wäre oder oder irgendwas in der Art weil.
Also die gleichen Unternehmen die Herford irgendwie bei der datenschutzgrundverordnung verteidigt hat.
Kommen und so weiter die schmeißt er jetzt hier vor dem Bus also insofern ist das nicht so ganz.
Also aus den Diskussionen in den Verhandlungsrunden ist so ein bisschen hervorgegangen das hervor.
Mit vielen der Plattformen die von seinem Vorschlag betroffen sind einfach nicht vertraut ist.
Er hat mal gesagt also tinder oder GitHub hat er noch nie benutzt er kennt die eigentlich nicht und ich habe mal in einer Verhandlungsrunde.
Eine halbe Stunde damit verbracht handfaust zu versuchen zu überzeugen das geht hab eine Firma ist und keine nicht-kommerzielle Plattform.
Und also das zumindest hat funktioniert und im Text geschrieben drin das irgendwie Open-Source-Software developing platforms.
Nicht betroffen sein sollen immerhin aber das war wirklich eine halbe Stunde hin und her weil der wirklich überzeugt davon war GitHub wäre irgendwie ein nicht kommerzielles Community Projekt oder so einfach nur weil Leute das kostenfrei benutzen können.
Also das ist auch.
Ja ja aber also dass das irgendwie sehr schwierig weil also ich glaube.
Seine Herangehensweise ist also wenn eine Firma Geld verdient und wenn.
Der Upload von user-generated-content irgendwie centralis für ihr Geschäftsmodell dann müssen da ja irgendwo Urheber ausgebeutet werden.
Also ich habe dann versucht ihm das.
Beispiel Kinder zu erklären wo selbstverständlich Kinder nicht funktionieren würde wenn Leute dort keine urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalte hochladen könnten also Fotos aber das deshalb trotzdem keine Fotografen hungern.
Weil irgendwie Kinder in keine Lizenzgebühren zahlt denn in aller Regel laden die Leute da halt ihre selfies hoch.
Die überhaupt nicht irgendwie von professionellen Fotografen gemacht wurden oder so aber das ist irgendwie das ist ihm nicht vertraut also.
Wie viel viel viel klarer kann ich es auch nicht erklären warum das so ist.
Aber für ihn sind Online-Plattformen eben YouTube und Facebook und die haben schon genug Geld und die benutzen ja auch schon fehlte aber da fehlt dann auch das Verständnis dass die Filter die z.b. YouTube benutzt.
Bei weitem nicht in der Lage sind alle möglichen Urheberrecht.
Zu erkennen also Content-ID ist schon irgendwie state-of-the-art und kann nicht nur genau also exakte Kopien von Videos erkennen sonst z.b. auch Melodien.
Das ist schon relativ technisch versiert aber das war's dann auch also wenn z.b. jemand in einem.
Youtube-Video ein Gedicht vorliest oder womöglich noch ein Gedicht das in eine andere Sprache übersetzt wurde.
Ja so dann kann Content-ID das selbstverständlich nicht erkennen und also das heißt diese Technologie die da gefordert wird die gibt es eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Ja also das ist auch so ein so ein blinder Fleck in der Argumente,
John der Verfechter von Artikel 13 weil es wird ja gesagt also alle die gegen Artikel 13 sind in der jetzigen Form das sind irgendwie die Vasallen von Google und.
Aber wir hatten letzte Woche eine Anhörung im Binnenmarkt Ausschuss zum Thema illegale Inhalte und die einzigen die dort positiv über algorithmische Filter gesprochen haben wann Google und face.
Die kleine Unternehmen die Akademiker die Zivilgesellschaft sagen alle diese Filter sind in Holz.
Und führen massenhaft zu Verletzungen der Meinungsfreiheit und sind vor allen Dingen nachteilig für Randgruppen also da kam dann solche Beispiele wie das z.b.
Menschen die auf Arabisch oder in kyrillischer Schrift kommunizieren ganz oft Opfer von irgendwelchen Filtersystemen werden weil die halt denken das wären Terroristen oder das wären russische boards.
Einfach weil das halt die Daten hergeben mit denen diese Algorithmen trainiert wurden.
Es hat ja bei der CDU schon gute Tradition Gesetze zu verabschieden die angeblich irgendwie Google an den Kragen gehen sollen und am Ende Google stärken also es ist ja beim Leistungsschutzrecht wirklich genau dasselbe Dilemma.
Aber sie lernen es einfach nicht.
Nicht direkt also damit hat sich ja Forstern doch nicht so in der Gänze durchsetzen können also in seinem ersten Entwurf stand drin dass es unveräußerlich das heißt also ein Verleger muss Geld dafür verlangen ob er will oder nicht.
Das ist jetzt doch ein bisschen abgeschwächt worden also jetzt steht drin.
Also dieses Leistungsschutzrecht soll dazu führen dass die Verlage faire Vergütung erwerben können.
Dann steht aber in den Erwägungsgründen die das ganze erklären übrigens das Listen in einer Suchmaschine ist aber keine faire Vergütung.
Also mit anderen Worten sie finden das irgendwie nicht ok was in Deutschland passiert ist nämlich dass Google eine gratis.
Bekommen hat aber sie haben auch keine Lösung wie man das verhindern kann weil sie wollen die Verlage nicht zwingen Geld zu verlangen.
Wir wollen aber gleichzeitig sagen nee also das geht aber nicht dass das Google dann umsonst kriegt nur wie das funktionieren soll das auf der einen Seite die Verlage entscheiden können ob sie Geld verlangen oder nicht das aber auf der anderen Seite google doch auf jeden Fall zahlen muss.
Das ist völlig unter also es ist Seiten im Quatsch Text irgendwie.
Ja also ich meine ich glaube das muss inzwischen.
Zumindest den Leuten die für das Leistungsschutzrecht lobbyieren auch irgendwie bewusst sein also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der Axel-Springer-Verlag wirklich immer noch glaubt dass Google am Ende bezahlen wird.
Manche meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen glauben das vielleicht wirklich und stimmt deshalb für das Leistungsschutz.
Aber also ich glaube bei Springer ist die Erkenntnis inzwischen dann doch auch durchgesickert da muss man sich natürlich die Frage stellen warum wollen die das.
Tim immer noch öfters bekommen raus durchdrücken und da hatten wir eine ganz interessante Anhörung im Rechtsausschuss also wo ein Anwalt von Axel Springer uns als unabhängiger Experte präsentiert wurde vom von der Parlament Verwaltung.
Und der hat gesagt es geht beim Leistungsschutzrecht überhaupt nicht da drum dass irgendjemand Lizenzgebühren zahlen soll sondern es geht da drum.
Nachrichten Aggregatoren und Suchmaschinen einfach vom Markt zu verdrängen.
Und jetzt wird wahrscheinlich auch Axel Springer nicht so größenwahnsinnig sein dass sie glauben dass Google am Leistungsschutzrecht zugrunde gehen wird das heißt es geht um die kleineren Aggregatoren und der Sinn des Ganzen ist.
Große Verlage den Großteil ihrer Leserinnen und Leser durch direkte Besucher Ihrer Homepage bekommen.
Die kleinen Verlage aber vor allen Dingen durch sogenannten Will Ferrell Traffic also alles was über links kommt von Social Media Suchmaschinen Webseiten und so weiter.
Und das hatten die deutschen Verlage auch mal ganz gut dokumentiert also.
So vor 12 Jahren mal einen lustigen Streit mit Günther Oettinger auf Twitter wo so diverse Online-Redakteure mal ausgepackt haben und gesagt haben wo kommt eigentlich ihr Traffic her.
Da hat man halt gesehen also bei den großen Zeitungen wie FAZ war das so 70% direkte Besucher der Homepage und bei kleinen Regionalzeitungen und auch bei so spezielle Spezial.
Portalen wie heiße waren es dann er sich.
Central Traffic das heißt mit anderen Worten wenn man es schwieriger macht von Suchmaschinen und Social Media auf Verlags Angebote zu verlinken dann killt man damit die kleinen Verlage und das ist vielleicht auch Sinn der Sache.
Ja also ich glaube wirklich.
Wir das im Plenum am 4. Juli noch kippen können weil die meisten Abgeordneten die waren auch schon hier als die,
Satelliten und in den letzten Tagen höre ich doch häufiger so stimmen dass Leute sagen oh wir müssen doch ganz schön aufpassen dass das jetzt nicht zum Mac.
Da wird.
Und das ist ja schonmal eine gute Ausgangsposition also die Abgeordneten sind irgendwie auf das Thema aufmerksam geworden wir sind sich sehr wohl bewusst das Netz.
Sozial in my Europawahlen sind und dass die Öffentlichkeit hat schaut wie sie abstimmen werden,
und ich glaube was jetzt ganz ganz wichtig ist ist dass wir dieses Momentum nutzen und.
Irgendwie lautstark protestieren nicht nur auf der Straße auch irgendwie dafür sorgen dass das Thema weiter in den Medien bleibt also auch so diverse.
Youtuber die durchaus irgendwie so bei Jugendlichen der ganz große Reichweite haben haben das Thema aufgegriffen also LeFloid hat was dazu gemacht.
Meatman Jack der auch bei den,
der Protesten schon eine ganz wichtige Rolle gespielt hat und also es gibt ein paar internationale Youtuber wie z.b. Philip defranco und pewdiepie die dazu was gemacht haben und die haben also Millionen von views auf ihren Videos.
Und es gibt ja quasi so eine ganze Generation mit der vielleicht auch selbst wir gar nicht mehr so richtig in Kontakt sind die auf das Thema jetzt aufmerksam geworden sind und womöglich gar nicht wissen also was.
Machen können also ist vielleicht das erste Mal dass sie überhaupt irgendwie sich so mit politischem Protest auseinandersetzen und so.
Das heißt wir denken uns wir wollen das versuchen wirklich gegen das Thema zu protestieren als erstes gibt's jetzt am Sonntag eine Demo in Berlin.
Zu der rufen bislang auf also unter anderem die Electronic Frontier Foundation digital Courage die Piratenpartei die Grünen Energie Netzpolitik.
Und noch eine Reihe andere NGOs.
Wir haben auch weitere Parteien angefragt also es sieht so aus als ob das wirklich relativ breit und überparteilich werden könnte also die Demo beginnt jetzt diesen Sonntag 24. Juni um 11:45 Uhr.
Vor dem europäischen Haus der Unter den Linden 78 und.
Glaube ich bin ein Weilchen nicht mehr in Berlin gewesen.
Zentral und also die Demoroute geht eben vom europäischen Haus in Richtung axel-springer-haus dass ich auch ganz witzig finde und also es geht gegen upload-filter und gegen Leistungsschutzrecht.
Und also ich glaube das wird eine witzige Sache und hoffentlich kommt da auch wieder so ein bisschen Acta Stimmung auf und das Wetter soll auch gut werden also ich kann nur alle.
Aufrufen da vorbeizukommen das ist aber jetzt ist so der erste Versuch das Thema auf die Straße zu bringen daneben ist es natürlich jetzt ganz wichtig einfach die Abgeordneten zu kontaktieren.
Ich glaube.
In Deutschland ziemlich wichtig wäre die SPD die haben nämlich ausnahmsweise tatsächlich was richtig gemacht und im Rechtsausschuss gegen upload-filter und Leistungsschutzrecht gestimmt.
Das war aber letzten Endes nur eine Abgeordnete also bzw also.
2 von der SPD im Rechtsausschuss einen Vollmitglied und ein stellvertretendes das sind Silvia Kaufmann und Timo Wirth.
Und die haben sich bei dem Thema wirklich super klar positioniert und das ist toll und die sagen auch naja im Koalitionsvertrag steht Upload fehlt er sind unverhältnismäßig und dazu stehen wir.
Nur man sieht ja die Bundesregierung als ganze agiert durchaus anders und deshalb kann man sich jetzt nicht darauf verlassen das wirklich die gesamte SPD geschlossen am 4. Juli dagegen stimmen wird insofern wäre das.
Sehr wichtig da die Abgeordneten entsprechend zu kontaktieren also jetzt nicht unbedingt Silvia Kaufmann und Tiemo wölken weil die haben sich ja schon positioniert aber die anderen halt.
Und naja also bei der CDU kann man es auch probieren.
Und natürlich auch bei den anderen Parteien FDP grüne Linke wobei ich hoffe dass da die meisten sowieso schon dagegen sind.
Aber also das ist jetzt wirklich wichtig weil viele Abgeordnete Hand wahrscheinlich sich mit dem Thema noch überhaupt nicht.
Und wenn ihr jetzt doch irgendwie Anfragen von der Presse bekommen die sie eigentlich dazu stehen vielleicht von ihrer Lokalzeitung dann müssen sie sich dazu halt irgendwie verheilt.
Und insofern ja.
Und ansonsten eure regionalen Abgeordneten anrufen und die Lokalpresse fragen hey mach doch mal was dazu und was sagen eigentlich die Abgeordneten aus der Region.
Also mitkommen ist natürlich auch dagegen.
Startup Verband also es gibt irgendwie Kaffeeverband deutsche-startups oder so aber die Industrie als Ganzes,
also es gab ab und zu schon solche,
solche Briefe auch aus Ecken wo man vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte also ich glaube Bosch z.b. hat uns irgendwann mal eine Mail geschrieben dass sie halt auch irgendwie in ihrer.
In ihrem Konzern Alltag auf Plattformen wie GitHub z.b. angewiesen sind und dass sie sowieso ganz verantwortungsbewusst.
Urheberrechte umgehen und dass solche Maßnahmen halt absolut unverhältnismäßig sind und irgendwie den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland gefährden.
Die ich hoffe dass die weiterhin irgendwie die CDU bearbeiten weil irgendwie so mit einem CDU Wirtschaftsminister das beeindruckt den vielleicht mehr wenn Bosch sagt dass es Unsinn als wenn das irgendwie.
Weiß nicht digital Courage sagt.
Ja also Wirtschaftsministerium Anfragen und Justizministerium ist definitiv eine gute Idee.
Also das wäre quasi die letzte Chance um diese urheberrechtsrichtlinie noch zu verbessern.
Denn wenn wir am 4. Juli verlieren dann bedeutet dass der Text den der Rechtsausschuss da jetzt angenommen hat wird,
die Position des Parlaments und dann steigt das Parlament unmittelbar in Verhandlung mit dem rad ein und dann ist natürlich klar der Rat hat sich ja schon für upload-filter und da ist.
Leicht ausgesprochen und wenn das Parlament das auch tut dann kann man nicht erwarten dass in den trilogverhandlungen noch irgendwas zum Besseren verändert wird.
Seid die Frage wo genau zwischen den beiden Positionen trifft man sich das heißt wenn wir am 4. Juli die Abstimmung verlieren,
dann gibt es nur noch eine Chance nämlich ganz am Ende der Verhandlungen wahrscheinlich im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres die gesamte Richtlinie abzulehnen.
Das wäre aber.
Meiner Ansicht nach schade weil es ja durchaus gute Elemente dieser Richtlinie gibt dass es gibt eine verpflichtende Schranke für Bildungszwecke damit Bildung.
Institutionen auch grenzübergreifend irgendwie im Internet Angebote machen können es gibt ein paar Erleichterungen für Bibliotheken es gibt einen Schutz der gemeinfreien Werke also dass man nicht mehr in wie,
das in der Vergangenheit z.b. passiert ist irgendwelche Museen Wikipedianer verklagen können weil sie irgendwie Fotos von gemeinfreien Gemälden aus dem 17. jahrhundert bei Wikipedia hochladen und solche Dinge.
Nur diese positiven Punkte sind halt im Vergleich zu den negativen so klein dass das jetzt irgendwie.
Am Ende nicht ausschlaggebend sein kann nur also es wäre sehr sehr viel erfolgreicher und sinnvoller.
Wenn wir diesen dieses Ergebnis aus dem Rechtsausschuss jetzt im Juli ablehnen weil dann können wir die positiven Elemente der Reform noch retten.
Und trotzdem die upload-filter abschaffen aber es ist nicht die allerletzte Chance also das heißt selbst wenn wir es im Juli nicht schaffen dann gibt es zumindest noch die Chance.
Ganz am Ende bei der Abstimmung des Parlaments über das Ergebnis aus dem Trilog die gesamte Richtlinie abzulehnen.
Ich bin mir also mir fällt jetzt spontan kein konkreter Fall ein,
aber naja also zwar keine Richtlinie aber zumindest halt das Acta Abkommen,
ist einfach abgelehnt worden allerdings hatte da das Parlament auch keine Möglichkeit Änderungsanträge zu machen also das war eine reine ja Nein Frage,
das ist da Handelsabkommen leider immer so und da hat das Parlament dann am Ende mit Nein gestimmt halt auch nach entsprechenden Protesten aus der Zivilgesellschaft.
Absolut ja also ich glaube.
Es wäre schon sehr schade also wenn am Ende irgendwie die ganze Richtlinie scheitert aber das wäre dann eben nicht meine Schuld also ich habe alles getan um diese,
Vorschläge irgendwie auf eine sinnvolle Bahn zu leiten es ist auch nicht so als hätte ich,
in den Verhandlungen im Rechtsausschuss einfach gesagt irgendwie Leistungsschutzrecht und Artikel 13 wir streichen die jetzt einfach komplett.
Sondern ich habe konkrete Alternativvorschläge vorgelegt und gesagt okay.
Also das YouTube z.b. die GEMA bisher bezahlen soll das kann man schon fordern weil YouTube eben auch die Inhalte.
Erkennt also YouTube kann ja nicht behaupten ich wüsste nicht dass wir heute da Musik hochladen weil Content-ID findet diese Inhalte natürlich.
Und was was YouTube da macht ist im Grunde genommen.
Anstatt mit der Verwertungsgesellschaft zu verhandeln eben jedem einzelnen Urheber Song take it or leave it Angebot zu machen also du bekommst.
Diesen Anteil an den Werbeeinnahmen denen die wir dir zugestehen und wenn nicht dann bekommst du halt nichts und das ist natürlich in gewisser Weise.
Ja unfair weiß natürlich verhindert dass die Urheber gemeinsam verhandeln können das sehe ich auch ein und deshalb haben wir halt diesen diesen Alternativvorschlag den auch der.
Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten und für Verbraucherschutz schon angenommen hatten und der sagt eben also ok.
Bei solchen Plattformen die die User Upload wirklich monetarisieren müssen Sie für diese Uploads schon irgendwie eine Lizenz abschließen.
Also für die Arten von Uploads die sie entsprechend erkennen können aber es gibt eben ein Verbot von solchen Filter Verpflichtung.
Und das wäre auch einen Kompromiss gewesen der glaube ich in irgendeiner Form tragfähig gewesen wäre also der kam sogar auch ursprünglich aus der Fraktion von Herrn Voß.
Ideen hat polnischer EVP Abgeordneter namens Michael Bohny vorgeschlagen und genauso beim Leistungsschutzrecht also wir haben einen Alternativvorschlag auf dem Tisch,
der sein der ist schon den Verlagen erleichtert gegen wirklich im Urheberrecht Verletzung vorzugehen aber eben nicht irgendwie ein neues Recht schafft das das Verlinken im Internet behindert.
Also die Abstimmung am 4. Juli beinhaltet erstmal keine alternative Variante das ist einfach nur eine ja Nein Frage.
Sind wir mit dem Ergebnis so zufrieden ja oder nein wenn die Mehrheit mit nein stimmt.
Dann können zur nächsten Plenarsitzung im September wieder Änderungsanträge eingereicht werden und dann können wir eben diese sinnvollen Kompromiss Vorschläge noch mal auf die Agenda bringen,
und ich glaube also wenn wir erstmal eine Mehrheit gegen den aktuellen Text gefunden haben.
Dann wird es auch relativ leicht sein entsprechend für diese Alternativvorschläge im mehr als zu finden denn im Rechtsausschuss war es genauso also alle die.
Gegen den Vorschlag von Herrn Voß gestimmt haben haben für meinen Gegenvorschlag gestimmt und umgekehrt also es gab jetzt keine die gesagt haben das ist alles Mist und.
Wir stimmen einfach gegen alles.
Aber ist am 5. Juli 1 weil so.
Okay gut also es kann sein dass es,
auf den fünften verschoben wird aber wir gehen davon aus es ist am 4. und ja ich kann nur noch mal drauf hinweisen geht am Sonntag auf die Demo in Berlin wenn Ihr da seid und kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten am besten per Anruf.
In der kommenden Woche müsst ihr in Brüssel anrufen.
Und dann direkt vor der Abstimmung also Anfang Juli in der Woche sind wir in Straßburg da gibt's eine andere Telefonnummer.
Ja sehr gerne.